et pour en parler nous sommes avec
laurent jack o bélie pas parole du
rassemblement national bonsoir le
rendait covelli merci d'être avec nous
en direct quand vous entendez cette
défense peut-être un petit peu
maladroite veut nous en laisser juger
vous même de didier raoul qui se dit
voilà j'ai tout eu j'ai tout fait bref
est ce que didier rahout a pris la
grosse tête ou tout simplement il est
assez malin il se place sur une défense
voilà on ti système anti élites quelle
est votre réaction
moi ma réaction c'est de dire c'est
quand même dommage que le professeur out
en soi à devoir se justifier en étalant
son cv sur youtube
le professeur out et c'est un fait à
l'un des plus grands spécialistes dans
son domaine et on a beaucoup de lachamp
beaucoup de chance pardon parce que ce
spécialiste est français et de le voir
aujourd'hui obligés de d'énumérer tous
ses titres tous ses faits de gloire
c'est un peu triste parce que s'il le
fait c'est qu'il a été traîné dans la
boue par des laboratoires par certains
ministres qui l'ont traité comme un
hurluberlu comme un charlatan qui ne
savait pas de quoi il parle et je vais
vous dire ce qui est étonnant c'est pas
la manière dont il part on a l'habitude
d'un de sa faconde et de son style un
peu particulier dans ce qui est étonnant
c'est ce qui est révoltant c'est que
dans notre pays on a tout fait à
l'envers quand on a indiqué la route en
france qui préconise un traitement
contre le corona virus qui est une
terrible pandémie
le premier réflexe ça doit être de dire
on va mener une étude pour savoir si la
raison et s'il a tort on va lui donner
tous les moyens pour le faire et on
espère qu'on va trouver au plus vite la
bonne solution
et bien en france on après l'averse avec
ce gouvernement on a dit non il faut pas
l'écouter on ne fera pas les culés puis
apprendre à la ferme au niveau européen
et là pour le coup ça a été vraiment
foireux que ce que l'étude de discovery
n'aura jamais lieu
et puis après on a dit pis que pendre de
lui mais on n'a jamais
études officielles nationales en france
pour savoir si libre auxi le chloroquine
plus un autre médicament pouvait
empêcher l'évolution du virus en tout
début de contamination est bien le vrai
problème est le vrai scandale
il est la salle et moi je suis dans les
bouches du rhône j'habite à l'eau juste
à côté de marseille
eh ben je connais des personnes qui ont
été malades qui ont utilisé le
traitement du professeur à vous et qui
ont été mieux en quelques jours
ma crainte c'est qu'on ne sache jamais
vraiment et scientifiquement si c'était
efficace et qu'on ne le sera peut-être
même pas après la fin de l'épidémie
c'est là que le gouvernement a failli
laurent jacot mes disques quand il dit
didier rahout c'est pas justement vos on
a bien compris que quand il parle de
système vous dit non mais le fond du
débat il est ailleurs il est sur la
chloroquine mai mais quand même ça
revient ces histoires d'élite il ya une
haine une haine des vraies élites la
vraie élite c'est nous en réalité si ce
scientifique reconnue a besoin d'aller
sur ce terrain là c'est que peut-être
qu'il pense qu'il ya un fond vérité
justement sur l' usage de ces
chloroquine et que ça ne se soit pas
fait est ce que il ya justement deux
france qui s'opposent dans cette
histoire notamment
je ne crois pas qu'il y ait de france
qui s'oppose il y à 35 incompétents qui
ne savent rien faire au gouvernement
qu'ils ne comprennent pas la france
réelle et qu'ils n'écoutent pas à la
france réelle quand on a un professeur
raout en france on les écoute plutôt que
d'écouter une incapable comme madame du
sein ou un incompétent comme monsieur
vers en voilà la vrai que la réalité et
c'est vrai en économie c'est vrai dans
tous les domaines c'est vrai en culture
c'est vrai en terme de sécurité
on n'a jamais
accumuler un aussi grand nombre de
balles travaux gouvernement qui refuse
d'écouter ce qu'ils savent pillion qui
les toise qui les regardent de haut
plein d'arrogance plein de certitudes
alors que concrètement ils ne savent pas
faire je comprends que ça énerve le
professeur raoul
je comprends que ça énerve les français
de voir ces gens que tu imaginer il aura
fallu trois mois pour qu'il trouve des
masques trois mois pour qu'il trouve des
tests de seconde pour qu'ils arrêtent
l'hydroxyde rockin après une étude dont
maintenant tout le monde dit qu'elle
était pipeau c'est quand même très grave
et la colère des professeurs out
elle fait écho à la colère des français
de ce qu'ils vivent au quotidien dans
cette étude 27 étaient pipeau alors
c'est vrai qu'ils ont aujourd'hui fait
un petit air à tous mais sur une erreur
de codage c'est un petit peu technique
mais vous remettez en cause justement
cette étude cette revue qui est quand
même reconnu moi je ne suis pas médecin
un génie l'étude mais je ne sais pas en
tirer personnellement des conclusions
mais je vois des médecins qui montre des
des invraisemblances
elle déclare plus de morts en australie
qu'il y en a eu
les statistiques sont tellement parfaite
que ce n'est pas crédible
et apparemment la directrice commerciale
de l'institut qui a donné l ai donné à 7
à cette revue landes 7 serait en fait un
fake
ce serait une star du porno franchement
est-ce que c'est sérieux est-ce que là
on est dans le sérieux et est ce que le
gouvernement est monsieur vers ans
n'aurait pas dû prendre au moins
quelques jours pour étudier cette étude
et pour dire après si elle valait le
coup ou pas dans l'île se sont
précipités pour arrêterez l'hydroxyde
rockin et un jour on devra comprendre
pourquoi
hamon dernière question sur le
déconfinement c'est aujourd'hui donc le
grand stade 2 les restaurants les bars
qui roule applique au vide qui est en
marche également qui est en
fonctionnement votre réaction c'est une
bonne chose ou une mauvaise chose
décidément ils seront en retard sur tout
l'appli comique va arriver au moment où
à nous annoncer la fin de l'épidémie
long j'espère que ces gens là n'auront
jamais à gérer une pénurie alimentaire
ou une guerre pour la france parce que
vraiment ils ont fait montre d'un
compétences non aujourd'hui ce n'est
plus qu'un danger cette appli un danger
sur les données personnelles un danger
sur le traçage des individus ce serait
difficile de croire que c'est un atout
d'abord c'est volontaire très peu de
gens vont télécharger cette appli et
puis une fois encore pourquoi n'at-on
pas fait à ce moment-là si c'était
efficace il ya trois mois quand le virus
était à son pic
tout simplement parce qu'ils n'ont pas
été capables de même qu'ils n'ont pas
été capables de faire une étude
européenne avec discovery sur la
chloroquine ils ont été en retard
surtout surtout surtout ils ne savent
pas appréhendé ils ne savent pas écoutés
ils ne savent pas gérer
ils ne savent qu imposer écrit hier près
les français on a vu les limites de
cette démarche de ce mode de gestion
merci à laurent jacot bénie par parole
du rassemblement national d'avoir été
avec nous et on vient